passt auf ich mal jetzt in flaschen
trick dazu nimmt ihr erstmal die flasche
zwischen eure beine hoch und funky auf
ok hat nicht geklappt
hey leute was geht ab märz will kommt
bei einem neuen video hier mal wieder
auf einem kanal und so und ja ich hab
mir in letzter zeit schon dinge die
mädchen die jungs verstehen 1 und 2
gemacht und dinge die jungs an mädchen
nicht verstehen auch den ersten teil den
zweiten heute noch nicht und führt
deswegen gibt's denn heute ich wünsche
euch ganz viel spaß und werkzeuge welt
gibt auch reine show nicht gleich so
und dann will ich mal sagen wir fangen
mit punkt eins an und zwar kennt ihr das
bestimmt alle also die jungs die mädchen
bestimmt aus ihrer sicht heraus und zwar
schreibt von ihr ab und zu mal mit
mädchen okay ich habe eine freundin hab
ich schreib halt auch manchmal mit ihr
und bei mädchen ist es also die sind
auch ab und zu mal sauer
frag mich nicht wieso aber ist halt
manchmal so man merkt natürlich immer
als junger mann ein mädchen sauer ist
vor allem beim schreiben fällt ein
bisschen extrem auf und wenn man dann
fragte was ist denn los oder so dann
kommt erst mal zurück will gar nix was
soll sein und dann denkt man sich okay
ich schreibe jetzt erstmal ganz normal
weiter aber dann
da kommt plötzlich sondern text und in
diesem text wissel richtig runter
gemacht da ende immer und dann fragt man
sich dann mal okay aber wo ist bitte die
logik ich meine du kannst mir auch
direkt sagen dass die scheiße bin wenn
ich schon frage anstatt mir das zu sagen
wenn ich nicht gefragt habe keine ahnung
ist also verstehe ich nicht pech gehabt
so und dann kommt auch schon zur
nächsten sache und zwar reich letztens
in japan und gegenüber von mir sagten
zwei mädchen und die ganze zeit wirklich
ohne scheiß alle drei minuten ganze
waren zum glück nur irgendwie zu zehnt
in diesem abteil zehn leute saßen also
aber der ganze abteil hat nach ebenso
frauen gesammelt ich weiß nicht ob
irgendwie einige mädchen nicht lesen
können aber schaut doch vielleicht mal
hinten auf die verpackungen drauf oder
auf die spraydosen keine ahnung da steht
immer drauf wie lange das denn ungefähr
hält ist ja okay das stimmt meistens eh
nicht aber wenn da steht das hält zwölf
stunden dann sollte es eigentlich schon
fünf sechs stunden halten
das heißt ihr müsst euch nicht irgend
alle drei minuten irgendwo voll sprühen
mit diesem spray und dann zu richten wie
ein ganzer und salaten oder so dafür
könnt ihr auch übrigens viel geld sparen
da müsst ihr euch nämlich nicht jeden
tag eine neue dose kaufen weil wenn man
alle drei minuten sprüht ist die
bestimmt nach zwei stunden leer
dann kommt auch schon zur dritten sache
und zwar ich sag jetzt mal vorweg man
fragt der mädchen manchmal ob man
vielleicht irgendeine aktivität machen
kann ich meine jetzt nicht das was er
gerade denkt sondern halt sport zocken
keine ahnung und dann kommt meistens
oder zu 90 prozent aller fälle wie ich
bin dort voll schlecht
und ja dann macht man halt diese sache
und das mädchen das vorher gesagt hat
ich kann das eigentlich gar nicht ist
plötzlich 20 mal so gut wie du selber
und da fragt man sich warum sagst du mir
dass du das nicht kannst obwohl du genau
weißt dass du das übels gast kannst
versteht mich ja das war mal wieder so
drei punkte
und was ich auch auf jeden fall noch
loswerden möchte ich war letztens beim
einen youtube analytics unterwegs da wo
man hier als video beim bergwandern
videos bla bla bla und irgendwie 75
prozent meiner zuschauer ist weiblich da
freue ich mich jetzt ist ja ok aber
warum schreibst du heute die kommentare
warum guckst du meine videos und ja
wirklich freuen ansonsten check die
beschreibung instagram und co gibt am
hocheck soll gefallen hat ansonsten geht
sie auf der linken seite weiter mit
meinem letzten video das war hier
irgendwas mit drei fragen was mädchen
angeht und die auf der anderen seite mit
einem video mit meiner freundin wert
exakt auf jeden fall bei napoli nicht
vergessen wir sehen uns nächste woche
wieder im verlauf der nächsten wochen
drei nicht gibt fast keine luft mehr